hi guys my name is mimo and i'm a
culinary producer here at tasty my
background is in pastries one of my
favorite things to bake are brownies
brownies are so great because they're
fudgy they're rich they're chocolatey
and they're that sweet place between a
cake and a cookie i know we're all busy
and you might think you don't have time
to make dessert but today i want to show
you how to make a four minute 40 minute
and four hour brownie so let's do this
our first recipe is really easy and
comes together just in four minutes so
first i'm gonna add my butter into my
chocolate chip and put this in the
microwave to melt everything together
for 30 seconds and now we just patiently
wait and now i'm gonna dump my melted
chocolate into this bowl then i'm going
to whisk my sugar and my egg this is
just one of those recipes when you're
watching a movie and you crave a dessert
but you don't want to put in the effort
so you just go and whip it up really
fast with minimal ingredients and now
i'm going to sift in my cocoa powder i
like sifting it because i want it to be
all smooth then we're gonna use a rubber
spatula and mix it in there i love how
shiny it is this is definitely gonna be
fudgy and now for an extra added
chocolate flavor we're adding chocolate
chips i picked semi-sweet chocolate
because it's the perfect bitterness and
doesn't add too much sweetness to the
dessert our batter is ready and now i
have this microwave safe pyrex dish i've
greased it and lined it with parchment
and now we're going to add the batter
into it we're going to use an offset
spatula to smooth it all out that way
it's beautiful if you don't have an
offset spatula feel free to use the back
of a spoon smoothing it out also helps
your brownie bake evenly i saved a
little bit of chocolate chip to sprinkle
on top just for the aesthetic it doesn't
hurt to have more chocolate so go crazy
that took about two minutes to put
together and now we're gonna put in the
microwave for two minutes and now we
patiently wait it smells so good i think
our brownies all ready i'm gonna cut
this in half but no judgment if you
don't want to share with anybody you've
worked hard for four minutes so feel
free to enjoy all by yourself
look at that look at all that melted
chocolate fudgy center and it's that
simple four minutes and you have a
beautiful dessert and now let's taste
this brownie
mmm
this is so good and for something you
made in four minutes oh my gosh i don't
think you have to tell anybody it was
microwaved you can just tell them you
spent hours making this this is good but
i want to show you something even better
so let's go make our 40-minute brownie
this is a pretty standard recipe with
minimal ingredient first we're gonna
sift our flour and cocoa powder i'm also
gonna sift our baking powder i love
sifting the dry ingredients because it
helps me not over mix my batter and it
creates a very smooth consistent batter
for the brownie and now we're gonna give
this just a nice little whisk then set
your bowl aside and we're gonna start
with the big bowl i'm gonna add my eggs
and then now i'm gonna add my sugar and
we will whisk this together this looks
good and now i'm going to slowly add my
hot butter the reason you want to do it
slowly is you don't want to scramble
your eggs this is called temporary and
that is bringing everything up to
temperature slowly this is looking
beautiful and now we're gonna add our
salt into this the reason i didn't mix
my salt was the dry ingredient is
because the salt crystals are too big
and usually get stuck in this sifter and
now we're gonna add our dry ingredients
and we're gonna use our rubber spatula
to fold it in and again we don't want to
over mix the reason is we're looking for
a fudgy brownie and we don't want rubber
again i'm turning my bowl the opposite
direction as i fold it now we're going
to add our semi-sweet chocolate chip i
like semi-sweet because it's the perfect
balance between sweetness and bitterness
i'm just not a sweet dessert person i
like the perfect balance our brownie
batter looks beautiful and i have an 8x8
baking pan here it's greased and lined
with parchment now we're going to add
our batter into the pan what i love
about this recipe is it's so fudgy again
we're gonna use an offset spatula my
best friend to smooth it all out i'd
make these brownies if i want to make
something special but also feeling lazy
at the same time so i think it would
impress people but it's not show
stopping this looks good let's go put in
the oven at 350 degrees for about 25 to
30 minutes my brownies are done i've let
mine cool for a little bit you are more
than welcome to eat them right away but
if you want to get this perfect square
let it cool and it will cut beautifully
this recipe makes nine perfect squares
let's see how these look inside look at
that fudgy brownie with chocolate
pockets i have my milk let's try this
not a good brownie this one's fudgier
than the last brownie it has a nice chew
and it just melts in your mouth this one
is really good but if you're a chocolate
lover let's get into the next one to get
started on our four-hour brownie we're
gonna brown some butter i like to brown
my butter in a light pan that way i can
see the milk solids browning i'm using
two sticks of butter because i want more
flavor in it i want more fat i want it
to be decadent i want it to be show
stopping when you're browning butter you
always want to do it on low heat and
constantly stir so what you're seeing
over here are the milk solids and this
is what you want to brown so we want
this to sink to the bottom and that's
what's going to give you the deeper
nuttier flavor just don't rush it take
your time you don't want to burn it also
like who doesn't want to take a break
while they're cooking and just steer
butter as soon as you see the brown bits
you want to quickly remove it from heat
and put in a different container because
you don't want to overcook it while our
brown butter is still hot we're going to
mix it with our sugar and adding hot
butter into your sugar is going to give
your brownie the beautiful shiny
exterior in my opinion this makes a
great dessert right here we can just
stop now and call this dessert we're
going to set this aside to cool and
we're going to pull an espresso shot
because we're fancy like that i like to
add coffee to my chocolate desserts
because it just helps enhance the
chocolate flavor but if you don't have
an espresso machine don't worry because
you can add regular coffee you can add
cold brew you can even add stout it's
just a nice way to add complexity to
your dessert so i'm gonna show you guys
how i pull my shot at home i'm gonna add
about 15 grams of espresso i'm gonna use
my knife and brush it off i'm gonna use
this little guy to push the coffee down
now i'm gonna attach this to the machine
now we pull we're looking for only two
ounces all right we got two ounces of
espresso let's get back to our batter so
next we're gonna add our egg star sugar
i like to add it one at a time that way
it's well incorporated so we're gonna
mix this for about two to three minutes
until it gets lighter in color and this
helps us get air into the batter next
we're gonna add our espresso
vegetable oil
and vanilla extract our wet ingredients
are all ready so now we're going to sift
our dry ingredients now we're going to
sift together our flour cocoa powder and
baking powder again we sift because
we're going to break up these lumps if
you don't have a sifter you can just get
a whisk and whisk everything very well
we can add our salt if the time
commitment makes you scared honestly
just give it a try i promise this recipe
is not that hard now we're gonna add our
dry ingredient into our wet ingredient
and slowly fold it and again i'm turning
my bowl the opposite direction as i fold
in the wet ingredient into the dry it's
almost mixed but not quite i'm going to
add my chocolate now because i want to
stop mixing it right when everything is
incorporated and i don't want to over
mix it in this bowl i have a mixture of
semi-sweet chocolate and milk chocolate
and i'm going to set some chunks of
chocolate aside because we're going to
use them as garnish and i've broken them
up into different sizes because i just
want big chunks of chocolate i want
little melty chocolate so the milk
chocolate is gonna help balance the
bitterness of the dark chocolate now
i'll add my batter into my 8 by 12
prepared baking pan look at all that
chocolate
there's like half a pound of chocolate
in here again we're doing the same thing
spread it using an offset spatula this
is a recipe you want to make if you want
to feel fancy and if your friends love
chocolate like me last thing we're going
to do is garnish it with our chocolate i
want it to look perfect and rustic at
the same time you got to find that
balance and now comes the secret we are
gonna chill this for two hours and you
thought you were gonna work for four
hours but there's a lot of down time in
this recipe chilling it for two hours
helps develop the flavors it gives it a
shiny top you can even leave it in the
fridge overnight if you want but we're
not that extra alright i'm gonna go put
this in the fridge and relax for two
hours and i'll be right back we're back
it's been chilling for two hours you can
already see the difference the batter is
more firm there's shine into it so it's
ready to be baked i'm gonna go bake this
at 350 for about 35 to 40 minutes i know
it's been a long time but i promise it's
worth the wait our four hour brownies
out of the oven and let it cool for
almost an hour and we're at the finish
line but before we cut into it i want to
sprinkle some sea salt i'm gonna cut
this into eight generous pieces i'll
start in the middle she cuts so
beautifully i can hear the crunch on the
top and feel the gooeyness of the middle
this is a very generous piece and anyone
who spent four hours making a brownie
deserves it let's check one of the
pieces look at the middle it looks
perfect it's dense it's chocolatey i
cannot wait to try it this is definitely
my favorite the hints of the salt on the
top the mixture of the milk chocolate
everything it's just perfectly balanced
i definitely recommend leaving it in the
fridge for two hours because it makes a
difference alright that's it today we
made a four minute 40 minute and a four
hour brownie if you have any questions
leave it in the comment i'd love to hear
from you just remember there's always
time for brownies i hope you like this a
chocolate katie's making me say this bye
guys
[Music]
you